hello this is John from technical
support we see some unusual activity on
your computer and we think you may be
infected with a virus but don't worry we
have special disinfection software go to
this website download that and I'll help
you clean your system only problem with
that scenario is I'm not from technical
support there's no virus on your
computer in fact my name is not even
John and in fact that special
disinfection software that's about to
make things worse
let's take a
look okay what just happened there well
you've been hit by a rat and a bad one
and yes there are in fact good ones but
we're going to talk about the bad ones
in this video what's a rat well it's a
remote access Trojan a Trojan is short
for Trojan Horse it's basically a piece
of malware that's wrapped inside another
piece of software so maybe it's a
program that proclaims to do something
good or harmless or entertaining but in
in fact there's bad stuff inside it a
remote access refers to the fact that a
bad guy is going to be able to remotely
control your system so here's our bad
guy and what he's going to be able to do
once he has the rat installed on your
system that special software he's going
to be able to see everything you type on
your keyboard including all your
passwords in fact he can even type
things in as if you had typed them in
complete control he's going to see
everything that comes up on your mon
monitor so all the sensitive
confidential information you might be
reviewing not only today but a week from
now you'll still be able to see
everything that you see he'll be able to
have direct access to your disk you'll
be able to put malware on there maybe
ransomware maybe encrypt all your files
and make you pay him in order to get
that information back or just delete it
all he's going to have access to your
webcam and to the microphone on your
laptop top how about that for creepy in
other words he can turn these things on
even when you're not aware of it and see
everything you do and listen to
everything you say that's what a remote
access Trojan would do there's other
things called remote access tools that
can be used by a help desk for
legitimate reasons in order to do a
couple of these kinds of things to see
what's working on your system and help
you diagnose a problem but in the hands
of a wrong uh actor this becomes a rat a
Trojan and this guy has complete control
over your system okay let's see how this
different types of infections can occur
where you become infected with a rat so
the first one we already took a look at
this is basically a social engineering
attack and in this case the bad guy is
going to call this guy and when he does
he's going to instill in him a sense of
fear uncertainty and doubt fud there's
going to be a sense of urgency you need
to do something now because we don't
want you to stop and really think about
this we want you to just act and what
this guy's going to do is go onto his
laptop he's going to go over to the site
that is controlled by the bad guy he's
going to download this stuff and now his
system is infected with the rat and this
guy has complete control over his system
let's take a look at another example how
about a popup occurs this guy is on his
laptop minding his own business surfing
the web and all of a sudden a popup
appears on his system and the popup
gives him instructions the instructions
could be that he just goes to this site
and downloads the disinfection software
because it's telling him you've got a
virus and by the way this is from some
well-known antivirus company that it
claims to be that it really isn't or it
could be that it tells him to use his
phone and call and then the person he
calls leads him through the same type of
scenario but the same results occur in
both of these the popup is just the way
to initiate the action but the user is
actually infecting thems in both of
these cases and then one more that we'll
take a look at is a more silent kind of
case in this case they're going to get
an email is going to come from the bad
guy into his system and this email is
like a fishing mail email or something
of that sort and it's going to tell him
to click on a link it may not tell him
that he's been infected or it might it
could be either one of these
circumstances it could say that it's
coming from his bank and he needs to
install new software in order to access
his accounts or it could say we're from
such and- such antivirus company or such
and such operating system company and we
found a virus and we need you to install
this software once again same scenario
he goes over to the bad guys's site
downloads an app downloads software and
now he's under complete control this guy
now has a command and control server
that allows him to do whatever he wants
on the good guys
system okay so what can you do to
prevent this from happening to you well
there's a lot of things in fact that's
the good news first and most important
have a good backup if everything else
fails you want to be able to go to your
backup and recover so make sure you have
that do that now next thing is make sure
that you patch your systems I know it's
inconvenient sometimes to stop what
you're doing and put on all of those
vendor Patches from all the different
apps and all the different os's but if
you don't there may be a vulnerability
that the bad guy is going to exploit
that gives him the remote access Trojan
capability onto your system another one
is learn the tactics techniques and
procedures of the bad guys in other
words how do they go about doing what
they do if you understand how your
adversary works then you'll have a much
better idea of how to avoid what they do
and you won't fall victim to it so be
aware educate yourself then if you do
think you need to call tech support for
a problem if they call you and report
that they found an issue I'm going to
tell you first of all generally
operating system companies do not call
customers out of the clear blue so you
should suspect that something is up
neither do application vendors for the
most part either so if you do think for
some reason you want to check this out
say okay uh I'll give you a call back
and don't take the number that they tell
you then you go and look up the number
for that company and you call them
directly and then you can find out so
you do a separate call that you've
initiated and you know where you're
actually calling get all of your
software from trusted sources don't go
to just any old App Store and download
stuff because that may have a Trojan
inside it and you may have just infected
yourself so as best possible know that
your St software comes from trusted
sources use antivirus inpoint detection
and response software the EDR stuff is
used more in Enterprise environments AV
very common uh on user retail systems
but use these Technologies because they
can sometimes detect these Rats the
well-known ones and stop them in their
tracks and then as another sort of
safety measure use multiactor
authentication on all of your accounts
don't let it just be a user ID and
password that gets you in because the
guy controlling the rat May
remember control your keyboard and when
you type in your password they get your
password then they can log in as you but
if they also need to have possession of
your phone uh in order to get your
biometric to open the phone up or to get
into the app you know with an SMS
message that goes to your phone it makes
it harder for them now of course they
could have a rat on your phone as well
so there's a lot of different things
that could be involved here but
multiactor authentication certainly
makes the job harder for the bad guy
and then one of the other things you
could do is basically turn off the
camera or put a block uh put a piece of
tape put something over the webcam on
your laptop and only take it off when
you plan to use it that way if someone
is on your system then they won't be
able to see anything and you'll have at
least a little more peace of mind in
that case they actually make little
devices that you can stick on that allow
you to slide and and open and close the
camera so look for that kind of
capability as well
so there's a lot of things you can do
here that's the good news and I'll just
say if John from tech support gives you
a call best thing you could do just hang
up don't get infected by a
rat thanks for watching if you like this
video please like And subscribe and
don't forget to hit the notify button so
that you'll be aware of other videos
like this when they come out